[Música]
muy buenas tardes
i
a quién de ustedes les gusta el cine
a todos un día como hoy hace diez años
estaba con un grupo de mis amigos viendo
el cine
y como todas estas cosas que pasan en
grupos siempre de si se decide ver la
película que está de moda la película
que le gusta a la mayoría de manera
democrática en esa ocasión estaba de
moda igualito
los primeros 15 minutos de la película
no les voy a mentir me sentí un poco
incómodo porque éramos los únicos
adultos sentados en la sala de cine pero
posteriormente la peli ty la película
nos atrapó la trama la historia de este
pobre robot que tenía que enfrentarse a
un mundo posapocalíptico en el que los
seres humanos vivían en el espacio y no
tenían conexión entre ellos porque
consumían tecnología de manera
capitalista extrema
gracias a wally ya muchas otras
películas de ciencia ficción todos
nosotros hemos concebido el concepto que
tenemos ahora de futuro
saben por ejemplo que en brasil en
méxico actualmente
[Música]
saben ustedes que actualmente en brasil
en méxico existe
existen trabajando dos robots por cada
1000 habitantes
esas cifras se incrementan a 14 robots
por cada mil habitantes en canadá 18
robots trabajando en eeuu por cada 1000
habitantes
el foro económico mundial nos plantea
dos escenarios completamente opuestos
para el 2022
la tecnología puede eliminar 77 millones
de empleos al 2022 por otro lado la
tecnología también es capaz de construir
133 millones de nuevas fuentes de empleo
frente a toda esta situación muchas
veces como economista como investigador
social la gente se me acerca y me dice
cuál es el futuro del empleo para el
futuro del trabajo cómo nos va a ir con
estas nuevas tecnologías que están
entrando al mercado
muchas veces cuando incluso quiero
responderme a mí misma esta pregunta me
encuentro
en este debate
a un lado tienen a jack ma director
ejecutivo de alibaba y por otro lado
tienen a él
el director ejecutivo de otra empresa
muy importante en el área tecnológica
está
estos dos grandes influencias del sector
tecnológico se sentaron en los últimos
días de agosto y se pusieron a hablar
sobre el impacto que va a tener la
inteligencia artificial en el empleo en
el trabajo en la gente
por un lado jackman chino de origen dice
la tecnología es espectacular la
tecnología es inteligente pero los seres
humanos somos más inteligentes
el otro lado de la moneda el almost dice
la tecnología va a llegar a ser mucho
más inteligente que el ser humano y en
algún momento vamos a tener que
realmente de tarde nuestros factores
productivos al sector tecnológico
para que pase el escenario que dice el
señor más dentro de las áreas
científicas dentro de la ingeniería se
habla de la singularidad tecnológica
algunos deben estar ya familiarizados
con este concepto la singularidad
tecnológica dice que va a llegar un
momento en que las máquinas van a poder
auto mejorarse de manera recursiva es
decir van a poder mejorarse
automáticamente y van a poder tomar
control de muchas cosas que a nosotros
no les vamos a dar control como ser
humano
hoy vengo ante ustedes para comentarles
que como economista y como investigador
social quiero promover y quiero
oficialmente declararme en jackman
la tecnología es inteligente pero es
mucho más importante colocar siempre en
el centro al talento del ser humano
en países como el nuestro países en vías
de desarrollo el desarrollo tecnológico
se absorbe es decir nosotros no somos
productores de tecnología pero
necesitamos el talento de nuestra gente
para poder absorber la y mejorar
nuestros procesos productivos
por otro lado frente a este mundo
globalizado en el que todos los días nos
bombardean de información y tecnología
la clave para que podamos ser únicos y
mantenernos en el mercado mundial como
economía es valorar a nuestra gente
nuestro esfuerzo nuestro trabajo a
nosotros
en este sentido han surgido muchas
preocupaciones de cómo podemos
adaptarnos al mercado laboral
tecnológico y como desde el punto de
vista económico esto va a llegar a
afectarnos como seres humanos
hollywood ya hizo su papel con nuestras
mentes y películas como estas que se
grabaron en los 80 ya nos dieron un
mensaje en el que nosotros según viaje
al futuro estaríamos ahorita
siguiéndonos a nuestras casas en
nuestras patinetas voladoras nuestros
autos voladores y todos vestir y amos
como siguen vistiendo los 80 por lo que
la película nos mostraba sin embargo
muchas de estas cosas siguen siendo
ciencia ficción pero algunas de los
adelantos tecnológicos están permitiendo
hacer nuestra vida más cómoda y cambiar
la forma en que vivimos
cómo va a afectar esto directamente al
mercado laboral la pregunta en realidad
es cómo nos estamos preparando nosotros
para esta realidad en la que nos
encontramos
en agosto de este año también tuvo el
gusto de conocer a una persona súper
interesante para que el rock periodista
española que vino al país a comentarnos
acerca de sus investigaciones del
mercado laboral para que el escribió un
libro que se los aconsejo a todos que se
llama know max los trabajadores del
futuro
qué es un nombre un nombre es una
persona que no solamente tiene las
habilidades técnicas para poder manejar
la tecnología sino que tiene y por ti
tiene como fortaleza las habilidades
blandas las conocidas como soft skills
que lo hacen capaz de adaptarse a los
diferentes ambientes de trabajo
para que el rock hay muchos autores del
área de prospectiva dicen que la
sociedad que se nos viene es una
sociedad líquida eso quiere decir que
cada uno de nosotros de aquí 20 años
vamos a tener que adaptarnos a las
cuentas de trabajo que se nos ofrecen
y para poder hacerlo tenemos que tener
las habilidades de resiliencia trabajo
en equipo y trabajo de bajo precio
por otro lado los nombres de
trabajadores del futuro también van a
presentar una forma de trabajo más
horizontal que vertical qué quiere decir
eso que no vamos a tener las mismas
nociones de trabajo de ingresar a una
empresa desde asistente y soñar con
llegar a ser el gerente general las
generaciones futuras ahora sueñan con
poder trabajar desde sus casas poder
trabajar para empresas en otros países
moviéndose a través del mundo
la tecnología y la digitalización nos
permite ese cambio en el mercado laboral
ya que desde los últimos años gracias al
internet nosotros podemos trabajar
haciendo un clic y comunicándonos con
personas alrededor del mundo
sin embargo necesitamos un esfuerzo
desde desde el punto de vista educativo
y nosotros como futuros padres y padres
enfocando la educación de los hijos en
una actividad en actividades que les
permitan desarrollar las habilidades
blandas
pero eso no es lo único el escenario
también los grandes analistas de
perspectivas como el foro económico
mundial nos dice que las profesiones no
van a ser las mismas
que las carreras van a evolucionar con
el paso de la tecnología por ejemplo
hace 10 años
muchas de las universidades aún no
tenían las carreras de ingeniería de
sistema y ahora
se están buscando cientistas de datos
especialista no solamente en
programación de algoritmos sino también
en análisis de la información para la
toma de decisiones tanto de las empresas
como del sector público y cientista de
datos por ejemplo es el ejemplo ideal de
la combinación de las anteriores
carreras tradicionales para poder
adaptarse a las necesidades del mercado
mundial
por otro lado existen muchas carreras
que van a perder espacio en el mercado
laboral porque las tecnologías para
absorber ese tipo de actividades iban a
tener que emigrar actividades que estén
relacionadas con la tecnología o
actividades que estén relacionadas con
el trabajo con las personas
sin embargo
volvamos al inicio lo más importante
ahora es trabajar para poder afrontar
los desafíos que vienen del mercado
laboral a nivel mundial
este trabajo requiere el esfuerzo
conjunto no solamente de nosotros como
individuales sino necesitamos a la
universidad adaptando adaptando sus
carreras a las necesidades del mercado
mundial por otro lado el sector privado
adaptarse a todas las necesidades del
mercado mundial y por último el sector
público que nos apoye con las políticas
públicas que permitan que las carreras
futuro sean poco a poco tomadas como
carreras del presente porque si bien
este futuro que estamos viendo no tal
vez nosotros no vamos a hacer los
factores que van a tener entrar a
manejar drones dentro de nuestras
empresas pero los niños que están
caminando por las calles alrededor de
nosotros y los niños que caminan por
todas las calles de nuestro país van a
tener que asumir el desafío de que ahora
la tecnología a ser parte de sus vidas
todo el año
como construimos es
esta frase me gusta mucho porque es un
antropólogo de la universidad de harvard
especialista en sociedades
este antropólogo lo que hace es analizar
cómo podemos alcanzar objetivos en común
cuando la sociedad se pone como objetivo
trabajar en común
y nos dice
qué tan innovadora en realidad es una
sociedad depende más del nivel de
interconexión social que de la capacidad
de innovación de cada uno de sus
miembros
en otras palabras sabemos que todos
somos talentosos el talento existe en
nuestro país y lo vemos hoy en este
evento en el que podemos escuchar muchas
experiencias
es nuestra capacidad de conectar para
generar y construir una economía más
fuerte preparada para hacer para laborar
en la que tengamos mejores oportunidades
para nosotros
hola
[Música]
y